hello bob how are you thank you conan
thank you i'm
very well how are you i'm doing uh very
well and i can tell that you're thrilled
to speak to me this must be a big deal
for you
you seem this is i mean of all the
things you've accomplished in your life
this has got to be at the top i can't
get on anything else
[Laughter]
i guess i had that coming um you know
there's so much to talk about but i
first i have to ask you
i've gotten to know you a little bit as
much as you'll allow and
uh i worry about you during this
pandemic are you bored what are you
doing
to stay occupied what do you do with
your time
since uh you're you're quarantined well
thank you thank god for football because
that that has
that has saved my life um and we've only
got a few more days left and then
and then you know it's over but yeah you
ever played football did you
i played the game yeah you know i don't
look like it i don't look like a
i mean i'm only five eight but um
i i i was i was running back in high
school and uh and actually it was quite
good and
as a matter of fact i would i didn't i
didn't realize you were you were running
back
in football that's impressive i was i
i was up for a um a football scholarship
at notre dame which is
wow hard to get yeah but there's one
play
there was one play kept me out of of
getting the
the scholarship at notre dame it's the
uh you know the the fake handoff into
the line you know with a quarterback
like appears to hand you the ball and
and
you have to pretend that you have it
yeah you're pretending you
yeah well i used to yell out i i don't
have it i don't have it
they wouldn't tackle me you know you
you know you're not supposed to do that
it really it really hurts the illusion
it hurts the illusion bob that's what
notre dame said